[Music]
the bow of a Chinese Coast Guard ship
hits a wooden boat that was carrying
supplies for Filipino troops on a
landing ship that's used as a floating
Outpost less than an hour later a
Philippine Coast Guard vessel in a
Chinese ship hit each other Manila
blames the collisions on dangerous
Maneuvers by the Chinese continued
Chinese blocking and interference by
Chinese vessels with our regular and
routine rotation and resupply missions
RoR to BRP sheram Madre may lead to
disastrous results but Beijing said the
Philippine boat deliberately sailed
across the path of its Coast Guard
vessel in the first incident and a
Philippine Coast Guard ship reversed
into another one of its vessels in the
second this violates China's territorial
sovereignty international law and the
Declaration on the conduct of parties in
the South China Sea and undermine the
peace and stability of the region China
claims nearly all the South China Sea
but the Philippines insists a unbacked
ruling from 2016 rejects this the area
where the Collision took place is only
200 km away from the Philippines but
nearly 1,000 kilm from hinan Island the
nearest Chinese
territory confrontations in the South
China Sea between the Philippine and
Chinese coast guards have become
increasingly tense over the past several
months but these incidents are the first
where government vessels have collided
with each other many fear there could be
more to come if both sides fail to
diffuse the situation Barn below Al
jazer
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer